I'm not gonna boot your entire
generation Generation Y me I got it
you live on your phones you have no idea
how to function like normal people in
the real world
miss Wicklund this isn't the real world
this is Canada
oh it's Lulu and lemon condescending
riot girls Coleen coalition I would like
to invite you both to my party a senior
party Oh
we've seen your boys only invites
sophomore girls to parties for one thing
god knows what he'll say all you need to
handle any situation in life are the
warrior one and word or two positions
girls master those and you a master
anyone who kiss your [ __ ] yeah why did
your dad takes me like 37 times oh my
god he's making us work tonight
you all think history is so boring well
what if I told you during World War two
there were Nazis
right here in Winnipeg under the
self-proclaimed Canadian feuless so like
Canadian Hitler nein nein nein nein so
much nine it's almost 10:00
Canadian Nazis with the original panda
inertia years or was the proxy what is
abroad see ah ah like a foot talk Nazis
made of bratwurst are you guys trippin
on the pot I need both of you to me
solve this quite clear case sorry
destroy everything that threatens anyone
before anything that you love that's the
ogre way we can do this we do tons of
stupid stuff with our adults oh sorry
sorry booth that
we're being in top a little sausage men
the cost attorneys tower forever
blood-filled
damn yoga poseurs this is so busy it's
just beyond basic
you